this is the scene at the 5th pub house
in downtown Toronto on Friday night I
saw just in the end of the bar kind of
realized it was him from afar went up
set a low Justin how you doing yeah it
was like a drink SAS for jacket coke
made that friend similarly doing in town
citizens friends and family and just
come in here watch the good brothers
here but it didn't take long for Justin
to get in touch with his musical science
he has to play this that's a grand piano
but it's not set up as such as
electronic piano we got set up for him
and he almost he just went off to the
races himself played five songs we
locked the doors for everyone who was
inside the to witness it Justin play let
it be by the Beatles his own hits Ori
and even some classic Beethoven check
out this musical flare he does at the
end of his set I see he was extremely
humble very generous with all the
customers and people that came by to say
hello to him sign a couple autographs it
was a couple of pictures involved
Bieber's class act behavior comes after
the tumultuous European leg of his tour
where he lashed out at fans and even
stormed off the stage in Manchester
but Justin looks much more at peace
performing for this intimate crowd in
Toronto the next day he's photographed
shopping in Toronto's Yorkville
neighborhood onlookers say Justin
politely made way for others as he
walked alone down a busy sidewalk